wir wollen jetzt direkt in die usa
blicken zu unserem us komponenten
herbert bauernebel mir nun zugeschaltet
herbert die ganze welt spricht jetzt
natürlich über den gesundheitszustand
von donald trump bisher gab es nicht zu
viele informationen dazu ändert sich das
heute im laufe des tages wird er oder
werden seine ärzte sich zu wort melden
es wird damit gerechnet tatsächlich ist
es ja so dass es seit freitagabend kein
update mehr gegeben hat kein
medizinisches polizei das wurde damals
also gestern ausgesendet vom weißen haus
selbst über den großen e mail verteiler
der angerichtet wurde für journalisten
die im weißen haus arbeiten und
natürlich auch andere journalisten rund
um die welt und da wurde eben bekannt
gegeben dass zwei behandlungsmethoden
begonnen wurden für den amerikanischen
präsidenten einem eine mit dem motto
wenn der swr und die zweite mit einem
antikörper cocktail einem
experimentellen einer amerikanischen
firma das ist der letzte stand seither
herrscht mehr oder weniger punkt stilles
haben macht einen tweet vom präsidenten
selbst gegeben wie gesagt es geht mir
gut und dann eingeschränkt hat denke ich
und dann hat auch noch in
blockbuchstaben das wort love liebe
getwittert man sieht hier schon ganz
deutlich dass offensichtlich der
präsident hier eine ganz andere tonart
jetzt anlegt konfrontiert mit einem
deutlichen wir möglicherweise tödlichen
virus